I think the biggest like standout moment
for me was definitely the American trip
yeah because it wasn't really Mom and it
was like two and a half weeks in which
we interviewed a crap ton of amazing
guests I tell you what was an was a real
highlight for me when I interviewed you
the day that Putin invaded Ukraine we
did that in February I've forgotten
about that yeah and by the way we raised
uh over 55 000 pounds for Charities that
work in Ukraine people enough smart
people or smarter than us people at
least are asking questions like what is
the positive vision
for people like us why should anybody
join our tribe whatever that tribe is
Right we've spent quite a lot of time
opposing things saying well that's wrong
and that's stupid and that's but why
what what do we have to offer the world
what what does our way of thinking what
does what do the questions we ask have
to add to the conversation yeah because
it's not enough to be against something
yeah you can't base an identity on being
anti-something I think for the
foreseeable future I feel that it's our
job to stay and it's our job to fight
foreign
hello and welcome to a very special
episode of trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster I'm Constantine kitchen and this
is a show for you if you want
interesting or sorry we don't know what
the show is about
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People we have neither for you today
because it's just me and Francis talking
about the year that's just been and the
year that's coming up so Francis welcome
to the show welcome to the show to you
too it's been a long and interesting
Year yes uh huge for us in some ways
also quite difficult in other ways
absolutely it has been a year of
contrast it's been a year of ups and
downs of changes of incredible
experiences it's had it all really well
the the I think the biggest like
standout moment for me was definitely
the American trip yeah because it wasn't
really a moment it was like two and a
half weeks in which we interviewed a
crap ton of amazing guests I was on
Temple then we were on Joe Rogan we
interviewed Bill Burr we had that crazy
Sam Harris episode that that blew up all
over the Internet uh what was your most
memorable moment to be honest with you
it was the America trip that was was it
was it had this strange almost
ethereal-like quality to it where apart
from a small blip at the beginning do
you remember with the all the equipment
where we didn't have any equipment when
we started yeah and then we had to go I
do remember
apart from that the rest of it went so
well I'm like I was I found myself
thinking is this a dream yeah like every
day had that surreal dreamlike quality
where we went to the Daily wire and then
we were interviewing Sam Harris and not
the Delaware no the daily that would be
a meeting of the minds wouldn't it yeah
I can imagine they wouldn't get on that
well but it was it was an incredible
experience and it was so fun and it was
it just showed us what was possible as
well yeah it did and speaking of what
was possible we're obviously sitting in
our new studio not entirely complete I
mean the neon lights that people will be
used to seeing uh were broken by one of
the builders he was installing them so
it doesn't sound like bubble distance
doesn't sound like Builders at all so
we've got a few little bits to finish
off and this room in the studio itself
is looking good but we've got more to do
and the office and Green Room part of
the studio is nowhere near finished uh
so that will be a job for next year but
we started the year in our law studio
and by the end of the year we had to we
were forced to leave that which is the
the Eternal journey of trigonometry
people haven't seen uh the truth about
trigonometry particularly part one we
talk about you know being kicked off out
of Studio after Studio but here in in
this place we have a more or less
long-term home we've built this entire
place from scratch it was just one big
empty room and we've made it the way we
want and we've still got things to add
so I'm excited about next year as well
uh but what were some of the other
highlights of last year for you do you
remember yeah so I mean some of the
guests we've had on the show in the last
year I mean think about some of our most
popular episodes Louise Perry yeah
absolutely brilliant Peter Zohan Peter
zahan fantastic William Costello was a
superb but yeah talking about incels
yeah it was yeah uh I know we released a
whole batch just around do you remember
when we got ill with covid round about
that January moment which were very very
very good Africa Brook yes I think that
was probably the first episode of 2020.
I think it may well have been yeah yeah
and what a way to start she was
absolutely Sensational just a brilliant
episode there were so many special
moments in that last Studio
I tell you what was an was a real
highlight for me when I interviewed you
the day that Putin invaded Ukraine we
did that in February I've forgotten
about that yeah uh February 24th and
that's been a big part and by the way we
raised uh over 55 000 pounds for
Charities that work in Ukraine in one
evening in one raw show we raised 55 000
pounds yeah and that to me well first of
all I know that it will make a big
difference to people on the ground there
but also I think it speaks to
um how amazing our fans are and what
we've built here too because that showed
you know the number of people who uh to
watch and listen and pay attention to
what we do and who who wanted to support
us doing that it was incredible it was a
really special moment I I mean when we
said that it was going to be a
fundraising rule I mean I thought we
were going to make a decent amount of
money I didn't expect because I had to I
had to work up I was working up material
for my tools so I had to go and do a gig
and I was like oh but if I leave at 8 40
that's plenty of time you know we'll be
finished and it just kept going the
money kept going well I felt really bad
and because prior to doing it I messaged
a couple of our higher end supporters
who've given us uh bits of money uh here
and and there and I said to him look
we're going to do this fundraiser I'm
guessing we'll probably raise about I
don't know a couple of grand you know
you're a millionaire would you like to
match it and smart this is how you you
know why millionaires are millionaires
they all went now but I'll give you a
grand
because if they had much that they'd be
in for about 50 Grand each yeah um so
yeah it was it was incredible and very
surprising and I think sometimes you and
I don't really realize uh how amazing we
the thing we've built is and how much
people enjoy it and our community on
locals which has been brilliant as well
um and it's been a really interesting
Year from a personal perspective for
both of us as well for me uh my book
came out this year uh and I had some
fascinating insights into the way that
the whole publishing industry works and
books and everything which we can talk
about if you want and also Nikolai my
son was born incredible
he's seven months old now which is just
insane and that's been a complete
transformation this changed a lot of the
way that I see politics and life as well
you know
um I can now I truly understand well I
certainly wouldn't say that I'm becoming
conservative I understand why people
become more small C conservative with
time and I don't think it's time I think
it's life uh life decisions and life
events that really change that for you
like when I see the world through a
parent's eyes it completely changes how
I perceive lots of things like what like
for instance
um well I mean the obvious one is drugs
I you know me I've been as libertarian
as anybody on the issue of drugs but
when I think about do I want him to be
able to buy heroin at the pharmacy at
the age of 16 I think probably not you
know
um so Joy kill Joy exactly
um and I think
I think it's also made me realize
particularly on the trans issue which
we've talked to death frankly but it
won't go away and so we've got to keep
raising awareness of it
is when you see how small and vulnerable
and undeveloped also their brains are
when they're small you kind of go
they're not capable of making such
decisions and of course no one makes a
decision to transition at seven months
but you can see the progression yeah
from between where he is now and an
adult and you just go these are not
children are not capable of making
decisions of this nature and they're
likely to experience a distress and
teenage years and whatever
and they're going to be looking for
explanations of why they feel in a
certain way you know and we've
interviewed in the last few days we've
interviewed both Ollie London and Helen
Joyce which were both very powerful
interviews in their own way and that's
one of the things that I realized you
know a lot of young people are looking
for answers to the same existential
questions that human beings have always
been dealt with but now they've got this
[ __ ] thing in their hand that just
offers them this complete massive range
of choices and where in the past you
would have felt distress or discomfort
or questions about your future now
you've just got this portal to hell in
your hand
um and so it's made me more conservative
more more I don't know if they're right
it's conservative is the right word but
it's like my son isn't getting a
smartphone for a very long time I don't
think we understand actually what
smartphones are I don't think we
understand what they're doing to us I
think I think it was Jordan Peterson who
said this we've all become part of an
experiment and no one consented to and
they are manipulating our minds they are
changing the way we think they're
changing our attention patterns
in ways that we can't possibly
understand so correct decision and think
about us I mean you and I both basically
40 now so we grew up we look younger
some of us some on a good day some of us
look 38 yeah but
you and I grew up in an era when I was
growing up there was no internet no
there were no computers for a long time
in my childhood as well
um and so you were not constantly
plugged into the to this hive mind but
for young people nowadays
who are growing up now they've never
experienced that world they've always
been plugged into and and the thing is
you recognize particularly if you switch
off from the internet for a couple of
days and you just go and do something
out in the real world
the internet misrepresents reality yeah
particularly social media and yet if
that is all you know if you've grown up
with that from the beginning it distorts
your view of reality which I think is
where a lot of the sort of culture War
happens is because quite a lot of people
have just become so disconnected from
The Real World then these phrases like
well there's no difference between men
and women they become possible in a
world with in which you're not
confronted with reality
yeah and and that's such a great point
and it's also we get our ideas not just
of how other people are what they're
like as people and how well they're
doing or or not how they're well they're
not doing all of these things from
social media
and it doesn't exist it's a
misrepresentation you can think someone
is doing incredibly well and I mean on
one level they might be or it might just
be them showing edited highlights but in
that moment they might they might be
experiencing a tragedy and yet we look
at them and we feel jealous that we are
not them and the reality is but we don't
know we don't know and so we have we now
think that this alternate version of
reality is reality and we've all bought
it as well all of us I don't care who
you are we all think that way now yeah
and that you know you touch on jealousy
and that's one of the things that uh has
really shifted for me in the last few
years doing the show uh and uh Nikolai
being born as well it's like I am so
grateful for everything that we get to
do just the fact that we get to turn up
and this is our job it's like what
Wilbur said to us yeah you know we were
talking he was like this isn't a real
good job what are we doing here it's
Tuesday afternoon we're sitting here
with Jackie kids on you know and it's
something I've been conscious of for a
long time and um I've just I've really
forced myself not not that it was ever a
big thing for me anyway but you know
everyone feels jealousy every now and
again I the fact that you know people
commented on the fact that when we were
on America trip and we put those Vlogs
out which are brilliant intern Elliot
edited so well
and we were saying grace before meals
even though none of us is religious but
that's why we do because our practice of
gratitude is so important
um particularly when we're building
something and we're doing well and we're
having a lot of success and we grow
every year and that's really something
that I think we don't appreciate is the
constant growth how fulfilling that is
for us because you and I are both very
competitive and driven people
and I think I I always get itchy feet
suddenly throughout my life in in other
jobs that I've done other careers that
I've had once I start to feel like I've
got it down and I know how this works
and there's nothing new and there's no
problems to solve I started to get bored
whereas with trigonometry that really
isn't the case so and of course you know
seeing a child be born and watching
their first smile and like he's
literally in the last two weeks gone
from like constantly lying on his back
on his front to like crawling around
everywhere like I was having a shower
this morning and suddenly the door
opened and he crawled in you know yeah
um just watching that whole process it
makes you so grateful for for
everything and so I I've really been
I mean it sounds wanky but I've really
been blessed this year to to to to to
notice and appreciate all the things
that are going right yeah and and I
think it's important to do that because
I think a lot of the time we're so
conditioned especially in the west to
when things go right you just go oh
that's the way it should be that's what
life is life should be like this and
you're like well no that's not how life
works and by the way we're about to find
that out yeah with the economic
situation and the country and the
political situation because
it seems to me I mean actually Helen
Joyce who we recorded an interview when
I was bringing her uh when we were
driving in the car uh this is what she
was saying she said when I work at The
Economist 12 15 years ago he was all
about well you know we've got an extra
10 billion how should the government
spend it
that's over man yeah I think the truth
is and people I think people really
haven't caught cottoned on to this
the next few years are going to be
extraordinarily difficult I think
economically culturally politically and
socially the this notion that we've
enjoyed in the post-war period in the
West the
the world's always going to be better
your children are always going to be
better off than you were and
technologically I'll probably still be
the case you know they will probably
still live longer and and they'll still
have better gadgets and whatever but the
idea that they're going to be richer or
that it's going to be easier for them to
get a job uh young people you know it's
really really difficult for a lot of
people and I think that's only going to
get worse unfortunately I look I
completely agree with you I think that
the reality is is this is the beginning
of the tough times
we have seen chronic mismanagement by
successive governments for a long time
and now the chickens are coming home to
roost in particular with lockdown just
interrupt sorry I want to hear the rest
of your point but I would go I think
you're right about chronic mismanagement
by myself you'll bang on the money I
think it's actually a bigger issue and I
think it's a a broader problem it's a
global problem actually the the the way
that the economy has been managed the
getting into endless levels of debt
never even trying to pay it off is a
West wide phenomenon and perhaps extends
beyond that sorry no no no but uh again
don't absolutely agree and we are at the
very beginning I was thinking about it
the other day it kind of reminded me
like the covid is kind of like
when when we shut everything down and we
gave money what we basically were like
was like a landlord and everybody came
in for a point and we didn't have enough
beer so what do we do we just watered
down the alcohol everyone got their beer
but no one was getting pissed yeah and
all of a sudden what this point that you
were expecting to make give you that
warm fuzzy feeling and take you to a
better place all of a sudden it ain't
doing that and that's what we're all
feeling with our pockets with the money
that we've got
it isn't going to go to where it it used
to be I can see why you don't drink
anymore because it's a graphic way in
which you describe that just doesn't
give you the buzz it doesn't and I think
that's the hard stuff and Bitcoin
Bitcoin exactly and I think that people
more people are waking up to that fact
and you're looking at and we've raised
Bitcoin Bitcoin was the kind of get rich
quick scheme for Our Generation
but again with the SB with Sam bankman
freed or whatever his name is well that
wasn't Bitcoin specifically but I know
what you mean right crypto yeah I'm
talking about crypto in general because
for Our Generation really difficult to
get on the property ladder very hard to
so what are you going to do with your
money invest it in crypto that was the
dream and again that's gone by the way
so so I think a lot of people are
looking at the economic landscape and
thinking to themselves
I I don't know how this how I'm gonna do
what I'm gonna do with this I don't know
how I'm gonna make this work I don't
know what my options are everybody is
taking a real world pay cut and things
are getting more expensive well it's
almost like the period of time that
we're living through is just so
completely different to everything that
came before I think and I think you're
right the pandemic was definitely the
Catalyst then you have the war in
Ukraine and the war in Ukraine
people have different views on on how it
started and what's going on and what we
should do about it and whatever but it's
the first time in a very long time that
you've had full-scale military conflict
in in Europe between two major nations
in Europe uh in which everyone has felt
that they've been somehow affected by it
it has shown the very idea of
globalization combined with obviously
covered and China uh into the bin and as
Peter zahan talked about the
globalization is basically over and
that's not necessary that there are that
globalization did a lot of damage to
certain individual people but it was
also the foundation of Western
prosperity and prosperity around the
world in many ways so
that being undone quite rapidly in a
short period of time is going to have
massive impact on on on the world
and yet I also think that it it's going
to be an exciting time at the same time
uh because I I think particularly in the
cultural space and you and I have talked
about it with a few guests but
the one thing I am really conscious of
is those of us like you and I who made
it our business to oppose wok adhesi and
we did it for a number of reasons I
think you know would it be fair to say
that with you it was because a you saw a
destroying comedy and be your background
in terms of your family in Venezuela and
seeing what the far left can do when it
gets off off the rails yeah or were not
necessarily off the rails yeah when it
gets given an opportunity to run rampant
yeah but yeah that's fair yeah and not
dissimilar in my case I think in my case
it was I mean comedy was obviously a big
part of it but I'm also just someone
because of my background and because of
what my ancestors went through in the
Soviet Union you know the concept of
Truth has a has so much value to me that
I I wasn't prepared to go along with you
know two plus two equals five and that's
increasingly what we were we felt we had
to do so we started trigonometry by
opposing all this work idiocy and in the
process I also think we feel that there
are some people who go too far in
another Direction and and we've they
were always there but it's just I guess
we were feeling our way out and trying
to understand where where do we map into
this whole thing and I think now it is
the responsibility of people like us and
I hear different people having these
conversations like uh Peter Thiel gave a
talk to the nakcon conference and he
talked about positive vision for the
future and he doesn't exactly have one
but and I don't exactly have one and you
don't exactly have one but I think
people enough smart people or smarter
than us people at least are asking
questions like what is the positive
vision
for people like us why should anybody
join our tribe whatever that tribe is
right not the right-wing lunatics tribe
and the far left lunatics tribe but the
non-lunatic tribe why should anyone be
on board with us because we've spent
quite a lot of time opposing things
saying well that's wrong and that's
stupid and that's but why what what do
we have to offer the world what what
does our way of thinking what does what
do the questions we ask have to add to
the conversation and that's something
I've been thinking about a lot and
having my son has made me think about
that even more yeah because it's not
enough to be against something yeah you
can't base an identity on being
anti-something you've got to be because
if you look at music you know if you
every musical movement is a reaction to
the one before but it's not just
oh we are going we we dislike this this
and this it has its own sound it has its
own tribe it has its own way of being it
has its yeah you know there's many
different things that form a new musical
movement
so for us it's important to actually
think to ourselves well what do we want
to create because it's not enough to be
anti it's not enough to criticize
because let's be fair the easiest thing
in the world is to stand on the
sidelines and criticize people we can do
that all day long yeah but if you want
to make something better if you want to
actually be a force for good if you want
Society to improve then you need to be a
Creator absolutely and I think this is
one of the in some ways the tragedies
that I think about culturally that have
occurred as a result of this woke uh
idiocy is too many people who are very
creative have now ended up in a position
where like us rather than doing the
creative thing that they were always
doing instead they're just talking about
not being able to be creative or they're
you know they've gone from you know like
Winston Marshall is a very good friend
of ours or the two of us are Andrew
Doyle or you can you can go on and on
and on there's a whole list of creative
people who you to make comedy or music
or whatever who's now who's job now
mainly is to do something else and I
think that's something we need to
address actually and so
you know there's a few conversations
happening behind the scenes uh but that
is definitely one of the uh items on my
agenda for the next few years is how do
we you know I I'm tired of talking look
I haven't done stand up since the
pandemic began and I'm really happy not
doing stand-up but you know you and I do
raw shows three nights a week and that
is an outlet for both of our comedic and
creative energies but I think we need
more I think I think
um that we we've got to rather than
going you know diversity and wokeness
and all this stuff has made all the TV
comedies that we used to love [ __ ] we've
got to make our own stuff yeah you know
and I think that's that's the future
likewise with music likewise with
theater likewise with all sorts of
things and and people should know that
there is work being done behind the
scenes on on those fronts yeah we it's
got to happen and we've got to do it
because otherwise all you're doing is
complaining it's glorified complaining
and I always saying that glorified no
it's just planning yeah it's complaining
and I always see complaining like
scratching a bit of eczema where at the
in the moment it feels good
but
doesn't improve anything doesn't improve
anything and actually long term it just
makes you feel worse because all you do
is focus on the negatives and
eventually you just start spiraling
because all you see are negatives
whereas if you create that's much more
positive because it number one it's more
enjoyable and number two
good things happen when you create good
things happen you meet new people you
talk to new people new things New
Opportunities open and also as well
people see you creating and that then
Spurs them on to do their own thing and
that's how communities are built well
absolutely with trigonometry I think
it's I don't think we're blown our own
trumpet to say that a lot of people in
the UK didn't do what we do
back to when we started and they now do
it and I think part of the reason is
they looked at us and went well if those
two areas can do it yeah so can we and
that's great that you know that's
something that uh Joe Rogan always talks
about which is he wants as many as many
people as possible to have a podcast and
do a thing and whatever uh because
you're trying to build a you need more
people doing something than in just a
couple so uh you know we always try and
encourage people as well and I think
that's that's really important
um so I the question I wanted to ask you
is what have been some of the biggest
like mindset changes or ideas that
you've come up with during the last year
that have changed how you look at the
world
biggest mindset changes that
we had a a business meeting with someone
and we were talking about you know
trigonometry
and uh I I was saying and I made the
point of you know the you know the
mainstream media
and I was just sorry going you know the
problem with the mainstream media is you
know they take people and then they like
Comedians and they you know sanitize
them and whatever else and he just
looked at me went you know that's a
victim mindset
yes and I was like you're right and then
we and then I think it was you who made
the point who said something about the
mainstream media and he went you are the
mainstream media and we were like what
and he went of course you are you've got
hundreds over half a million subscribers
across all platforms you are the
mainstream media millions of people
watch and listen to every month you are
the mainstream now
and that was a very big moment where I
was just because I still in my head
Fringe is the wrong word we're not
Fringe but I I that's what if you see
what I'm saying I don't know exactly
what it's saying well the thing is the
the mainstream doesn't exist anymore in
the way that it did because uh in the
90s and the 80s if you were on TV
everybody knew who you were yeah because
everybody watched the same five channels
in this country now there are very very
few big stars like as we're sitting
recording this Jeremy Clarkson wrote a
piece about Meghan Markle in which he
compete he he fantasized about her being
subjected to the same thing as
um Queen Cersei in Game of Thrones and
it was quite obviously a reference to
that but most people didn't get it
because most people haven't seen Game of
Thrones even though Game of Thrones is
one of the biggest shows in the history
of the last 10 years right so that
mainstream celebrity and fame it just
isn't available anymore for the vast
vast vast majority of people even with
sport to be honest you know
um and so I think I think sadly for
everyone watching this is what the
mainstream is going to look like going
forward yeah and but that to me was that
was a really eye-opening moment where
someone was going no what you've created
now you are part of the mainstream and
you need to think act and behave like
that yeah and this idea that you know
you're on the site you know you're on
the side you you know you're Fringe and
whatever else you're not you are part of
the mainstream and you should accept
that and you should embrace that and you
should really step into that role and I
think that's very important for both of
us as we move forward what about
yourself
um I think
that's a big part of it I think the one
of the things that's happened this year
is my own audience has grown a lot
particularly on social media doing the
book and around the war in Ukraine I
meant that a lot of people wanted to
hear what I had to say so uh I think the
I'll end the year on like 200 000
Twitter followers which is insane and
it's made me sort of behave more
responsibly if I'm honest because I'm
like okay quite a lot of people are
watching this now I can't just you know
uh troll people in the same way or
whatever I I don't think I have a troll
people but I would be more abrasive in
the way that I communicated and also I
think fatherhood has also had that
effect on me as well where I'm like okay
this is you know I I have to I don't yet
have to be an example because you won't
have social media for a long time but uh
at some point I'm gonna have to be an
example and I take that responsibility
very seriously so that's been one of
them and the other thing is
one of the things that's happened over
the course of the last year in
particular is trigonometry has been it's
got bigger and bigger and it's meant you
know as we always talk about every time
the show gets bigger and we generate
more Revenue the only thing we ever
think about is okay we need to hire
another person so that the week we can
not be constantly overworked and
overwhelmed and dropping the ball here
and dropping the ball there and that
team has grown to the point where you
know in addition to me you and Anton our
executive producer we now have uh two
more full-time staff and five or six
part-time staff as well and that's a big
team to manage and you know whether we
like it or not I mean I always say this
you know we're two idiot comedians that
started a podcast but we now have like a
small business to run and it's
completely changed how I think about
the economy the tax system the whole
thing because and and the America trip
really helped to see things in a
different way as well because I don't
think in this country we quite
appreciate how difficult we make it to
to run a small business yeah it is very
and this isn't again coming back to the
victim mentality we are doing well in
terms of you know growing our audience
and putting out great content and and
I'm really proud of of the stuff that
we've created over last year
but it is not easy to run a business in
this country and when you go to America
and you see what what it's like over
there it does make you think and and
every time you know every time I turn on
the TV now and we've got these strikes
going on at the moment and all of that
and I sort of think the way we talk
about people who who've started a
business or people who are wealthy or
people who are successful it's almost
like baked in that they're somehow evil
in this country I don't know if you
think that's true or not but like we
always talk about you know they've got
to pay their fair share and you know the
top one percent of people in this
country pay 33 of all income tax and the
top 10 pay over nearly 70 percent
the top 10 pay nearly 70 of all income
tax how evil are they do you know what I
mean and I'm not saying there are people
at the very top who are getting away
with things who are avoiding tax or
whatever but the truth is I think if
people understood how [ __ ] hard it is
to run a business of any kind and most
small most big businesses started out as
a small business that that attitude
would be different
look I I agree with you by the way this
is an era where you and I have spied a
lot because you coming with with your
working-class credentials who's
responsible the richness you know yeah
look I the the problem is is that I
think when people talk about these
things they talk about it in an
emotional way yeah the reality is if
somebody who's doing very well for
themselves and it has a small business
which we're not yeah send us money
um we and let's say they're on six
figures that to me is not wealth
yeah that's someone who's doing well for
themselves and that should be celebrated
and all the rest of it I think what
people conflate with the two is
people like Bezos who you know use every
loophole possible in order to avoid
paying corporation tax allegedly
allegedly please don't sell it so if you
do actually be good to sue us because
then we get loads of publicity but I
think that's what people mean yeah but
there's like five people like that in
the world yeah right and they should all
pay more tax I agree yeah but their
company should but that's not what I'm
talking about what I'm talking about is
like we you and I had a big debate about
the the strikes recently right and the
nurses for example are asking for a 19
pay increase yeah which is unrealistic
well I I agree with you but my point is
something else which is this like for
example with trigonometry right we've
actually taken a huge risk in getting
the studio we spent probably the best
part of 40 Grand building what we need
right and that is that's we built a war
chest over the last year because we knew
we were going to step up to this level
yeah right but right now I'm sitting
here thinking well you know you and I
have already and Anton have taken a pay
cut just so we can keep all our staff
who we need to make the show and so we
can continue to pay for the student I'm
looking at our finances going we better
[ __ ] step our game up next year
because I don't know how we're going to
find the money to pay for everything
that we need you know and I think most
small businesses in this country
particularly in the current economy are
operating on exactly the same basis
they're just making do and just trying
to make sure they don't have to lay off
people around Christmas and so they can
have the money to organize a Christmas
party and all of that sort of thing and
that is
to a significant extent what a lot of
people who are creating the jobs in this
country are going through it's not like
their life is plain sailing no and yet
whenever we have these conversations in
public it seems to me like we demonized
the very people who create the jobs and
the opportunities for people in this
country by taking a risk man let's be
honest you and I didn't take any money
out of trigonometry and in fact we paid
our own money into trigonometry so we
could pay Anton the measly sum of 500
quid a month to edit all our episodes
right and by a mistake even as a
vegetarian
and we did that for what two and a half
three years right it wasn't until the
pandemic yeah that we started to take
that we started we got any salary at all
so you and we basically I mean not every
small business does this but you and I
essentially ruined our existing careers
and made ourselves very toxic in the
comedy industry because we believed in
what we believed in so we stepped up and
we took a risk and now thank God that I
don't believe in but thank God we've
created a small business that employs
over 10 people yeah and those people now
not only have a salary they have a
meaningful they have meaningful work and
and I don't know if you feel this way
but for me
other than family that is the number one
priority in my life to do something that
I believe in that I'm passionate about
and
the truth is this is the first job that
I've ever had when I felt like that you
know and I know that for many other
people who work on trigonometry they
feel the same way
they feel the same way and that means
something and that's valuable and yet
you know people who who do that and who
create those small businesses they're
sort of seen as these you know they're
somehow suspect yeah and I've I used to
feel that I remember when we had Rupert
low on the show you know a Rupert low
business guy uh owner of Southampton
formerly
Etc and he talked about you know we'll
ask off this and and there's always like
well you're this Posh guy with loads of
money and whatever
but the more we do this the more I
realize that while of course there will
be some people who get involved in all
sorts of shenanigans and whatever for
the most part people who start
businesses
are actually really important and of
course I don't think they get enough
credit in this country I think in
America they almost get too much credit
you know and there's not enough expected
of them in terms of contributing to
society but I think in this country we
have it the wrong way around as well
yeah well small businesses are the
Bedrock of our economy yeah they they
they always have been and hopefully they
always will be and that's why I was so
against a lot of what the pandemic but
the actions and the policies brought in
by the pandemic because it was to punish
the small business owner the average
person you know with the mom and pop
business as they call it in the states
whilst
effectively giving Helping Hands to the
huge conglomerates and letting these
small businesses go to the wall and it
was a tragedy and look I do agree with
you I think this cup this country is
built economically on the backs of small
businesses who do a lot of good who do a
lot of good not only for themselves and
for this country but as for society as a
whole you look
people the staff who come in and work
with us learn far more than if they went
to work for a CNN or an MSNBC or BBC not
to say that they they won't learn
because of course they will but when you
get involved in this type of production
you have to learn so many things you
have to be more flexible the skill set
that you generate as a result of that is
just far broader and deeper
and look I do agree with you that we do
that we don't give small business owners
enough credit I think the problem is is
that
our culture and our society when it
comes to finance and economics is
illiterate a lot of people don't
understand
they think that you know if you're an
entrepreneur or if you're someone who's
got your own business that automatically
means you're very wealthy when the
reality is a very high percentage of
small businesses fail most businesses
just make it to the end of the month if
they can pay everyone and the guy at the
top or the later yes unlikely yeah
statistically it draws a salary that's a
win jokes guys that's a win yeah
completely and and that but that's how I
mean trigonometry has been like that
since forever and yeah it's like that
now I think people see the numbers and
they see how many people we have on our
locals but this is literally it's hand
to mouth every month we built up a war
chest to be able to do this yeah that's
gone now and our costs have
I mean this studio costs about three
times to four times as much as our last
ones and that's why you and I are taking
less money and so is Anton just so that
we can manage it uh and you know I
already I'm already thinking you know
we've got to come back next year and do
this and do this and do this and do that
because you know I hope people watching
this understand this isn't this isn't
making Francis and constant and Wealthy
project at all in the slightest no this
has always been a passion project yeah
it always has and to be but the reason
is is like for us
to be able to do this as a job
is the best thing that's ever happened
of course it is in our in our
professional careers this is the best
thing that's ever happened yeah of
course it is because
it's very rare people are in control of
their own destiny even
top level comedians yeah
you know you're still at the whims of
say the wrong thing yeah you still and
the casting agents and the you know the
booking agents and the directors and
fashion all of a sudden you may be
flavor of the month one moment the wins
change for whatever reason and you're
not as desirable you're not as bookable
you know there's always a new hot young
thing that's coming onto the scene so
we're very blessed to be in control of
our own destiny yeah
yeah and we work very hard because of
that yeah and we work very hard because
of that and but there is something very
special to going into work and knowing
that you were the one who is going to
make the decisions that ultimately will
lead to success
or failing yeah absolutely so I suppose
the point of this section is give us
money
I'm joking but uh not joking
hey Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike so obviously not the only
pleasure I get from the locals is when
we show an intimate moment as we watch a
Japanese tourist get trapped in a tube
door that is good but I wasn't talking
about their locals I was talking about
our community on locals you mean the one
where you get phenomenal
behind-the-scenes content when you thank
you
when you get wasp incredible guests like
Jordan Peterson Brett Weinstein Bill
Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla Heather
Hein and others your questions not just
that you can get supporter only benefits
like trigonometry mugs monthly calls
with our other top supporters and even a
regular meal with me and Francis you
also get phenomenal behind the scenes
footage of our trip to America where we
met a whole host of incredible guests
and gave ourselves terminal indigestion
we're also starting to do monthly
giveaways for locals only the first one
will be signed copies of Andrew door's
new book plus you get access to an
incredible community of like-minded
people who share memes have fun
conversations and most importantly you
get to make new friends you can support
us with as little as seven dollars or
about five pounds a month or give us
more for the higher tier benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
you mentioned the pandemic Francis now
that seems to be over
I mean it's not yeah well isn't it no
what'd you mean well I don't I mean well
I mean covert is still there but I'm not
talking about that I'm saying that the
consequences yeah well that's what I
want to talk about yeah so as for me
this is the pandemic was everybody going
out and splashing the cash all of a
sudden we've woken up to the credit card
bill and everybody here is wondering how
the hell are we gonna pay it I agree and
I think obviously the the economy you
know poverty kills people yeah fuel
poverty kills people and it will kill a
lot of people this winter and that is
the product of partly of uh of many
things but one of them is is the
spending during the pandemic we have re
we have record access deaths in this
country at the moment and we warned
about this we had many guests on the
show to warn that these decisions that
were being made were not cost free and
yet we were uh you know people would
attack us and and you know say we're
being irresponsible and whatever even
though I think the truth is we've been
proven right on that that's also the
government's fault as well because the
government's scared people yeah they put
the fear of God into them and you know
people were terrified of this virus and
look let's be honest it's a nasty bug
well you and I have had it three times
yeah and the first well for you the all
three were quite bad yeah weren't they
the third one the third one was all
right the third one was all right
whereas for me the first one was barely
noticeable and the second the middle one
was really bad last year and the one we
had recently was it wasn't fun but it
was okay yeah yeah so it's not pleasant
for sure even for no longer young no
longer healthy but whatever we are yeah
whatever Middle East men middle-aged men
um but
and also it's important that we say this
chronic financial mismanagement and
there was a lot of money that was let's
put it bluntly misappropriately of
course but that's always going to happen
when everyone's in the panic and yeah
you know whatever not the text user of
course yeah but that was always going to
happen you know I haven't told the story
I think on camera before but it just
illustrates to me some of the lengths
that people were prepared to go to
and I I don't think people really get it
so exactly a year ago
um there was a protest in Parliament
square that silky Carlo organized one of
our former guests from Big Brother watch
which was against vaccine mandate and
Sophie our video editor and I Harman uh
who works for us as well and I we went
along uh to protest and we got it was a
miserable wet windy December day it was
really unpleasant we got to Parliament
square and there was I don't know maybe
150 people there yeah it was the dampest
of all squibs you know it was muddy
um and then we got there and because I'd
been quite outspoken about this issue
and people a lot of the people who were
there would have known me silky shoved
uh uh megaphone in my hand and you know
I said something I don't remember
why do I say I don't know what to say I
don't know what I feel today it feels
like a very strange time to be alive in
this country
I'm an immigrant to this country I came
here in 1995. I was brought up in the
Soviet Union and we saw the erosion of
our freedoms and civil liberties
immediately and also over time and
that's why I'm here and that's why I'm
talking about this stuff because that is
what is happening your rights are being
taken away I know that you might feel
underwhelmed by the number of people
here I know that sometimes it feels like
you're protesting you're speaking out
against it nothing's happening but know
that people are watching people are
hearing what you're saying and we've got
to keep it up we've got to keep it up we
can't give up we can't stop talking
about it we can't stop protesting about
it and when people see them more and
more people are against their stuff they
will support us and we will make some
changes thank you very much for coming
out today
and
when Sophie and I were coming back to
the studio I was so
I was so deflated by the whole
experience because I was just like look
we live in a country of people who've
given in yeah they've accepted the idea
that medical staff and care workers Etc
should be fired from their jobs that
they've done in many cases for decades
because they don't want to be vaccinated
for whatever reason
and they must be made to be vaccinated
and I and I I felt so for you myself I
think most of us felt that he was just
it was wrong yep it was a line that must
never be crossed but I I felt going back
on the tube or whatever it was I just
felt really deflated by the fact that so
few people were out there and we were
clearly not going to have an impact and
blah blah blah blah
um but eventually the government did
reverse that decision and what was
fascinating was that when when my wife
was giving birth uh she was planning to
give birth at home
uh and that's not how it worked out uh
you know she spent the whole pregnancy
being all holistic and blah blah blah
blah blah but we actually ended up
having to go to hospital at quite short
notice with her screaming in the back of
the car uh it was quite an experience
and then she had a long and it wasn't
long but it was arduous labor and she
was really adamant that she did not want
to have any medical intervention unless
it was absolutely necessary but he was
looking very much like she was going to
have to have a C-section and I knew that
you know it really wasn't going to be
mentally good for her she would blame
herself and she'd be upset and whatever
and it was a long I don't want to get
into all the details but it was a really
long and arduous labor and was very
stressful and actually her plan was that
I wouldn't be in the room when she was
giving birth she was gonna have it all
you know in the dark and blah blah but I
was in the room and I had to kind of
talk to the midwives and
sort of manage the whole process to some
extent
and right as things were looking really
bad
um this Midwife came in who hadn't been
there before and she was absolutely
brilliant and because of her because of
this one woman uh my wife was able to
give birth naturally and our son popped
out and he was all healthy even though
it'd been you know there was some risk
involved and whatever
and after all you know he was born uh he
was covered in myconium which is like
baby poo which means that he was getting
to the point where he was distressed in
the womb
um and uh when when he was born he was
this tiny little thing and he popped out
and the as he popped out this Midwife
started like rubbing him with a towel
and he and and she went pull the
emergency cord and like someone pulled
the emergency cord and like seemingly
dozens of people ran into the room and I
just stood in the corner like this as
they all did something and eventually
they cut down biblical cord and this
neopathologist came in looked at him
made sure he was okay and he was
absolutely fine
so happy ending and then when they all
left and it was just us uh with with our
son and this midwife
and uh she started asking us various
questions and one of them for the
medical questionnaire was uh are you
vaccinated she had to ask my wife
um and my wife didn't want to get
vaccinated because during her pregnancy
yeah because you know I think a lot of
women were concerned about it and who
knows if they were right or not but my
wife felt very strongly that she didn't
want to be and
this Midwife who'd been incredible
asked this question and I felt bad
because I was like well she I'm sure you
know she she'll think that my wife and
you know what made the wrong whatever
and I started going well you know it's
sort of making excuses almost and she
won't don't worry I'm not vaccinated
and I was like really and we started
talking about it and then eventually I
said so you must have felt very strongly
about the government trying to mandate
these vaccines
and she went yeah I was going to quit
and my son would not have been born the
way that he was born if she hadn't been
there you know and so when I think back
to that
pointless protest and whatever and I
don't know if it made any difference at
all but I felt that the stand that we
took and many other people took at the
time for what we believed in even though
who knows what impact we had but it was
important that somebody somebody made
that stand and by the way I probably
caught covid at that protest it's quite
possible because that was the day we had
it might have been at that protest or it
might have been in the evening where we
had one of our Lives yeah I remember it
so we either caught it there or we gave
it to everybody there who knows right
but it wasn't impact free my point is
this neither us being public about our
opinions at the time or go into that
process of doing any of the other things
that we did and yet in some small way I
feel like
the way he was born was a reward for us
making that stand you know and I think
during the pandemic we really found out
who's who
in terms of who's going to be there when
the vast majority of people go off the
deep end like Lemmings and that's I'm
sorry I know that people were scared but
that's what I feel people were doing
during the pandemic I think a lot of
people panicked I think a lot and people
in government too overreacted
um went too far I think red lines were
crossed on many occasions
and
I'll be honest with you man I don't
think
we're gonna get the sort of public
inquiry we need to make sure it doesn't
happen again and I think that the next
time there is a pandemic I think it will
be as bad if not worse yeah I I I agree
with you uh I I agree with you I think
unfortunately
nobody some lessons are too painful for
people to be able to
Digest
and I think the pandemic is going to be
one of those things
I think people behave some people
behaved so awfully
that it is probably going to be too
painful for them to look at their own
behavior
and to be able to analyze it
and actually learn from it
some people will some people will hold
up their hands and go you know what I
was really wrong on this one
I was really wrong when it came to
vaccines I was really wrong with the
vaccine mandates I was really really
out of line the way I spoke to certain
people but I don't think a lot of people
will want to look at it like that I
think a lot of people will frame it as
it was a pandemic what are you gonna do
and then move on and the sad thing is is
not learn from it
because I think that moment that we all
went through
I think it was a it was a moment which
revealed a lot of things
when moments of Crisis happen that's
when the mask slips with people yeah and
you actually see people for who they
truly are both good and bad of which we
have
in all of us but I think with a lot of
people you saw the authoritarianism come
out yeah you saw the desire to control
people you saw the anger you saw
also the fear and and how fear does
you know people say that you know
jealousy you know is is a very toxic
emotion and jealousy does create toxic
emotions and makes people do awful
things but in many ways fear does as
well because if you think your own
health or your safety is on the line
then you will do whatever it takes in
order to make sure that you are safe and
if that means someone throwing somebody
metaphorically in the way of Fire
the thing that bothered me about it was
irrationality as well though because you
and I look you and I also adjusted our
views over the course of the pandemic
and our own experience with covert was a
bit of a wake-up call because I think uh
we we were perhaps a little bit too
lackadaisical about it uh at times uh
you know I mean ultimately I think we
were broadly speaking on the right path
which was you know the vaccine is really
good for people who are elderly or
vulnerable but probably not necessarily
necessary for other people particularly
those who've had the disease before and
who've got some natural immunity and we
kind of stuck to that but the
rationality like when he was very clear
that lockdowns were not saving life when
it was very clear that masks didn't
actually prevent the transmission of
code when it was very clear that covert
vaccines are not effective enough at
preventing transmission
to demand that people inject something
to their body that we now know as we
knew at the time carries with a certain
risk to force people to do that just
uh
I think to me that goes beyond
authoritarianism and it is like I said
it's a red line bodily autonomy is such
a fundamental thing about what it means
to be human the idea that I don't get to
inject things in your body I mean it's
not complicated is it no but but people
were willing to invent all sorts of
excuses at the time and there'll be
people out there now who who demand that
and and it also it moved into other
Realms as well like you you it's quite
common now for people to go well someone
says something I don't like they should
be arrested yeah
arrested for saying something
and it just that creep of I get to
control other people because I don't
like what they do
there was moments during the pandemic
and we've talked about it before and we
were not as as trigonometry as a
business we were not ready to to
upsticks and move to another country we
weren't big enough we didn't have the
resources the finances we didn't have
money in the bank to be able to do it
but despite that me you and Anton were
sitting there going look if if this
other thing happens we have to think
about moving to America
and like one of two states in America
where you can have freedom still you
know because I just I just thought we
went so so far in this country and it
scared me and I'll be honest with you um
you know I love this country but
I have to say it fundamentally changed
my view of this country I think forever
yeah
it changed my view of this country I was
shocked
how many people
relished the petty authoritarianism yeah
and I don't use that word lightly they
loved it they did they absolutely loved
the opportunity to tell their fellow
citizen what to do how to do it when to
do it where to do it
and you just think this isn't the
country that I grew up in this isn't the
liberal tolerance society that I thought
that I lived in the amount of people who
just there's the Glee that they felt
that they could tell another person what
to do with their body where to go
how to behave
I I it really it disillusioned me
because I remember when I was a kid and
every time I went to Venezuela and
Venezuela has always been chaos it's the
way it always is you know it's Latin
America
and always remember coming back to
England and just as a kid even as a kid
like breathing a sigh of relief because
it felt sane
and I remember in the pandemic going
this is insane
this is the definition of insane the way
we're living the way that people are
behaving the policies none of this makes
any sense
and I was the one
uh look I'm gonna be honest I still want
to leave
do you yeah how come
I don't see a lot of future in this
country
why not
economically it's broken
I don't think we have the caliber of
politicians to to lead us out of this
either right or left this isn't a
partisan thing if I saw incredible
people on the left I'd be like yep
I don't see anybody on the right who's
got who's a strong enough figure to
actually come out and
be honest with the population
I don't see people with character or
Vision on either side I think
I think this is
we're in a for a really tough time and
if it was just a tough time but there
were people that I looked at who I
thought
we can get behind them as a country I
wouldn't be worried
that's not where my worry comes from the
fact that we are in this financial
situation it's the fact that I'm looking
at people in government in power
who is it
that's what worries me
foreign
I understand I I wonder though I mean if
you were living through the 1990s would
you have not felt the same
the 1990s yeah
what part of the early 90s John Major's
government or the end of Thatcher or
whatever it's all limping to the to the
death now to the whatever the [ __ ]
metaphors yeah limping into their own
grave right and then Tony Blair comes
along yeah [ __ ] it all up invades a
rock invades are right no but
you see what I'm saying yeah I do look I
I think to to despair at the fact that
our politicians uh not able to deal with
the problems that the country faces is
correct but where are you gonna go
I would rather go to somewhere and I'd
rather I'd rather go to America yeah
and look what who are the politicians of
of vision and Leadership there
Trump
an AOC an AOC
I just I I find the American Spirit
invigorating so do I so do I but the
question for us is you see I don't want
to leave anymore I think when we were in
America it was
exhilarating yeah and we we're gonna if
if we can fund them we will do two more
trips next year to go and interview big
guests and and and continue our
expansion and and we have a huge
audience in America you know I think uh
the UK is something like 40 in America
is 40 for us so you know we've got as
big an audience in America as we do here
but I think that
first of all I don't like running from
challenges number one number two America
has all these same problems not
economically quite as much but
culturally many other problems are worse
in the United States
um
and you want to have children
eventually and I have one already and
maybe uh more later
I know people who live in America now
who who are saying like I want to move
back because I can't face putting my
children in this education system you
know and also I mean if Temple will have
you believe and you know him and I
disagreed with him about this on his
show and he followed me on Twitter
straight afterwards but you know there
are a lot of people like Tim who are
pushing the Civil War narrative very
hard yeah and that's you know probably
because it you know it generates a lot
of attention but also because there are
people who are we saw this too when we
were in America there are many people in
America who are very polarized and they
have guns yeah right so
I I think I understand what you're
saying and I understand
but I also think that on these cultural
topics that we we talk about on the show
we can win the fight in the UK in a way
that you're not going to win in America
you're just the trans issue is not going
to be like it is in the UK no we're
winning here yeah we are winning and we
are going to win and you and I have put
uh reputations on the line and our
careers on the line to get people on the
show who could explain that issue to us
and once we understood what was going on
there was no way back right and the more
we talk about it the more we understand
that there's no way back and we're not
going to give up until that issue is
dealt with properly right and we're
making progress the Tava stock is shut
down and is being sued I'm not saying we
did that of course but we did have one
of the whistleblowers on the show and
other people talking about mermaids has
now been
exposed for what it is uh the gender
recognition you know we're making
progress and I believe on that issue we
can win the fight the Free Speech issue
is more difficult yep uh here than it is
in America but I just think we can make
more of an impact here and look the fact
is we're a British show man yeah see
that is true I think a lot of our
American audience wouldn't watch us if
we were just like you know the sixth
best Joe Rogan in America yeah you know
what I mean yeah yeah yeah completely I
I do understand that I do understand
that and it is a good point to make
I
to me the pandemic was
is something look we did very well
at the pandemic
we all improved ourselves massively the
pandemic helped to create this
it just was seeing what happened to the
country that I grew up in
to the people that I identified with
the behavior
the politicians
the rhetoric
it took me back I understand that I
think the other piece I would maybe add
is that you've got to realize that in
America a lot of that was happening at
any even higher level yeah and they went
more extreme and of course and the
Democrats are particularly in blue
States like New York but also I would
say that this is again you know like
that guy said to you it's victim
mentality I think this is an opportunity
for you to recognize the scale of what
we've created yeah you know people
sometimes say to me Constantine why
don't you run for Parliament and I'm
like because I'd have less influence
being an MP yeah doing trigonometry yeah
and that's true of you too yeah like we
are one of the biggest Independent Media
shows in this country yeah and
of course we don't have the ear of
government
but we are helping to shape the way that
at least our part of society looks at
things and things and we're bringing
interesting people on I think I think
I don't think we'll be leaving is the
truth no I don't think we'll be leaving
either and that being the case I think
it's time for both of us to to accept
the challenge yeah that's been thrown
down to us we've created this a lot of
people listen and watch our show listen
to our show and watch it
it's our job to to to stand up for what
we believe in and to bring on people who
we think are doing that yeah you know
and of course we're always going to give
a voice to different views and people
who agree with us and people who
disagree with us but I think
particularly on this authoritarianism
issue it's our job to be the voice of
people who don't want that in your
country and and the the most gratifying
comment that you've always said to me
and I agree with this the most
gratifying comment you and I receive
from people who come up to us on the
street or message in or whatever is you
got me through the pandemic and part of
that was for a lot of people hearing
that dissident voice going no we're not
accepting this no this isn't normal no
this isn't natural no it's going too far
yeah
all the catch phrases all the
catchphrases but yeah a guy came up to
me in the shopping mall uh once uh it
was a few months ago now and he had
these three little children with him and
uh one of the for people who don't watch
our raw shows which is like a current
affairs daily satirical show that we do
like a live stream every every few uh we
do the three times a week
uh the cat one of the catchphrases
whenever we talked about Jacinda done or
but particularly her or Australia was
like get back get in the camp yeah that
was a thing we're gonna need to bleep
out because YouTube uh I said it again
YouTube demonetizes any video with that
word in
uh
and
he came up to me and said mate oh thank
you so much you got us through the
pandemic and then one of these like
eight-year-olds went get in the camp and
he was like he doesn't know the other
part of it but my point is yeah you know
we contributed to people and a lot of
people said we kept them sane and
whatever that's our job man yeah and I I
understand the appeal and there are so
many great things about America but the
way I feel about it look at the studio
the reason the studio exists is partly
because we went to America and we saw
how people who do what we do in America
do it and they have their own compound
where they have a a nice green room and
a place for people to hang out and a big
studio and their own space and they're
not moving from residential apartment to
residential apartment as we used to do
that's why we've stepped up and I
believe our fans will back us they will
make it possible for us to carry on
doing this
and we gotta we gotta pay them back man
and I think that's our job you know
that's our mission that's our project so
I understand the temptation of the
United States I just think we got to
take that spirit and bring it here and
it's going to be [ __ ] hard because
lots of people in this country don't
want that they don't want the go get
mindset they don't they don't want that
they want to you know this is the thing
that really bothers me so much is like
so many people in this country just want
the government to take care of it of
course and but that's what the pandemic
exposed I know the amount of people I
saw on Facebook going oh the government
have to take care of me I'm like
what the thing is there's no such thing
as the government the government is just
other people in the country who pay
taxes so that you can get what you want
yeah that's what it is there's no such
thing as the government the government
is just the The Entity that administers
the money they get from other citizens
and why do you deserve special treatment
yeah
you know uh it doesn't mean we shouldn't
have a welfare state and the safety net
to catch people if they fall and we've
all been there to some extent you know
but
I think we need to you know we need to
step up man rather than running away and
and going well I'm I am disappointed and
you are with with the way that things
happen but we've got to step up that's
what I feel and we we've got to play our
part and you know we didn't intend we we
started a podcast to understand what was
happening in the world but now we are a
voice for some people cool and we have
to we have to do we have to do right by
them I feel
um
and so that's why I don't want to leave
I think when we were in America we
talked about it and look who knows what
the future brings
but I think for the foreseeable future I
feel that it's our job to stay and it's
our job to fight it's our job to fight
um you know there are a lot of people
who Who start a a show and and some of
them will have more viewers and more
followers and that's fine who they just
interview celebrities about you know
what was it like to be depressed and
what was it like to be this and how did
you become successful and those are
really interesting things to watch and
enjoy but I think for us we talked about
it being more of a passion project
and that's I think how a lot of people
experience what we do it's it's partly
about passion and it's partly about
bringing common sense and rational
discussion and on this discussion of
difficult subjects so that things
actually change as a result you know
we're not just creating entertainment
for people to just watch while they make
dinner there's also there's a mission
here too and I think we have a
responsibility to to be true to that
yeah
I agree with all those things
and I think what I was saying when it
was about America is just legitimately
how I feel yeah about my disappointment
yeah with everything that was happening
and the political class but I do agree
with you the reason that the reason that
we created this show
was because we wanted to find out what's
going on and now we will when we've seen
what we've seen and what we've
experiencing you see the injustices and
you see the things that don't get talked
about but they should be spoken about
and the thing that really annoys me is
when
people are too scared to have a
conversation and to actually be honest
and Frank about it and how the moment
certain subjects pop up people
immediately try and like almost like
whack-a-mole hit them on their head
because they don't want to address them
you know the migrant crisis yeah and
what happens is then people start
talking they just start saying
narratives things like you know these
people are desperate and they've come
over here and you know every person no
person is illegal whatever it may be and
that we should look after these people
and you go well look on one level of
course you are right but that's not how
real life works that's not how you have
a functioning country that's not you're
not even doing the right by these people
by doing that or their countries all
their countries and all you're doing is
facilitating organized crime but if
you're not prepared to have the
conversation that you're not prepared to
actually try and come to some kind of
solution
and that's what I think that the most
important thing that we do is is to
model respectful conversation about
right-wing talking exactly because the
only because by doing that that's the
only way you're going to come to a
solution that's the only way you're
going to be able to solve these
particular issues and there are several
examples where you can tell that that
has absolutely been the case I mean if
you look at the issue of grooming games
the episode that we've done that I'm
most proud of and I always say this is
with Ella Hill yeah
um I think she's an extraordinary woman
and that episode that we did with her is
an extraordinary episode I mean we're
talking to a survivor of gang rape and
abuse over a long period of time and
it's funny I mean that that and that's
all credit to her by the way because she
was brilliant that's why when we were on
Joe Rogan it was one of the first things
that we talked about because you know I
I knew it was going to come up one way
or another I mean you got in there with
it early with the Peter abant uh but you
know it needs talking about and look
where we are now yeah now everyone
accepts that the grooming gangs happened
now everyone accepts that it needs to be
dealt with now everyone accepted it's a
big problem I'm not saying we did that
we didn't do that there were many many
more people who campaigned about it but
people like Ella and others and so
whether it's the transgender issue
whether it's the migrant crisis whether
it and they'll you know people say well
these are right we will they'll be
left-wing points of course as well that
we've covered on the show you know our
episode with Julie bindle for example
right
um the the
SE things you know the first man through
the bridge always takes most of the
arrows but for whatever reason you and I
want to be that first man you know or
maybe we don't want to be we just feel a
duty to be yeah to some extent uh not
saying we're first on any issues before
people get carried away but we we we
feel it's our duty to address the things
that people don't want to talk about
that need talking about well the whole
point of trigonometry is that you go
into the eye of the storm that's the
whole point of it and that's what people
want from us is to go into the eye of
the storm and to talk about these big
contentious issues that people are too
scared to talk about the politicians
when they go on the question time they
will give empty platitudes because
nobody really wants to talk about the
truth of the subject whatever the
subject may be and that's really our job
yeah well speaking of question time you
reminded me that there's actually been a
lot of personal accolades that you and I
both have achieved this year stuff going
on you you've just had a tour and you're
about I mean by the time this out you
will have finished your dates and other
things going on what have you really
enjoyed this year I've really enjoyed
and this is going to sound wanky I've
really enjoyed the Journey of it
okay
don't agree it's not natural
um I've really enjoyed the Journey of it
I've enjoyed
where we started from the you know the
the I didn't
but no it's it's important it's really
you know
I always
when I remember when I started comedy
and I was working with comedians they
were always like going I can't wait to
to get off the open mic and I get on to
do bigger gigs I want to do this I want
to do that I don't want to be here and I
was always my attitude was always like
no you should enjoy this you should you
should remember this because if you
don't then you're not going to be able
to appreciate
what's gone and what is coming
you know
think about the first interview we ever
did where there was a beeping car alarm
and we had to run around and then the
person was Furious because it turns out
they'd come from a funeral and then we
had to our first ever interview started
with me giving a grappling apology
You could argue that's the way it's been
for the rest of it of time but you need
to go through those experiences
you need to go through the being asked
to leave Studios you need to be going
through you know the arguments
you need to go I agree with you but it
was [ __ ] hard it was hard and I I was
looking at our stats the other day
because a friend of ours started a
YouTube channel uh and
we we did 11 interviews yeah including
with Brendan O'Neill yeah Claire Fox and
Diana Fleischman and we'd been going for
two months yeah and we hadn't even got
500 subscribers yeah
but that's how hard it was it was really
hard and at this point we're paying our
own money yeah there's no guarantee of
success of course we're [ __ ] going
from Studio to Studio it was brutal it
was brutal
but we had to go through it I agree if
we had I didn't enjoy it though no no no
no no no but you did
you did do you remember when we first
went to the Soho theater to watch
Andrew's show and Diana froshman broke
20 000 views how excited we were yeah
and you went to me it's not always going
to be like this you've got a good
attempt your expectations do you
remember that yeah do you remember
walking out of that interview with
Brendan and being like oh this was
brilliant or when Sargon came and then
we had that Rush of subs and we got to
three and a half thousand
do you remember that yeah that was big I
remember you [ __ ] yourself when
interviewing songs yeah of course I did
because I saw my career disappearing in
front of my eyes correct do you remember
when we went to that conference and then
we first met Douglas Murray and then we
interviewed him and then the the
interview got cut short not for
technical reasons but because the
cleaner wanted to come in clean and she
had to kick us out it wasn't the cleaner
actually it was a woman who had booked
the room for something else yeah but you
assumed she was a Tina exactly yeah
because she was a woman
and
it was tough but there was Joy there
was a there's a famous yeah we you know
there was a Band of Honor and there was
a the lead singer was called Kirk and
I've heard of them yeah and on his
guitar he always had a sticker which
said the beauty is the struggle
and it is
because that's what makes you appreciate
it and the moments when you're in the
struggle that's what forges you that's
what makes you tough the fire it's not
the easy part it's not going on Rogue
and it's not I mean look America was
great but why was it so good the reason
it was so good for it is because he
starred in a pub yeah no one gave us
anything no and we went from that
to there
and if people had given us things and it
was it wouldn't have been as sweet we
had to do that yeah it's only by tabbing
that do you do you get the joy
not and even in those tough tough
moments there were Still Moments Of Joy
yeah
yeah it's true it's true I have to say
though I enjoy my life a lot more now
you know and it's been you know
obviously my son being born and all that
but it was the year it was the year that
I was on question time uh my book was a
Sunday Times bestseller I mean it's
embarrassing how few books you have to
sell together on that list it really is
and as I realize now no one makes any
money uh selling books basically unless
you you become like even if you're a
Sunday Times bestseller not particularly
yeah but but it's it's still an
accomplishment yeah uh and it hasn't
gone out yet and I can't wait for it to
go out but I did a debate at Oxford
Union and uh I did let's just say let's
just say I didn't hold back so I'm
looking forward to that coming out so
those are really exciting moments for me
this year in addition to obviously the
America trip going on Rogan uh
interviewing some of the guests
uh that we've interviewed over the
course of the last year uh and uh you
know this studio is is is the big big
Next Step yeah big Next Step uh and it's
a risk you know we we went we've jumped
uh perhaps a little bit further than
than we ought to have done if we were
being prudent but I think I I think and
hope that our ambition will be rewarded
I think it will be rewarded I think it
will be rewarded because
ultimately you need to overreach
yourselves at times because it's only by
doing that can you actually get to the
next level and a lot of the time you
need to make that leap
and we were forced to make that leap so
yeah but we didn't have to do this we
didn't have to build our own Studio from
the ground up basically because this was
just one empty room and now it's a
studio and with a green room and a
office area and whatever but we wanted
to do because we saw that
we did have to do it why
because we didn't have to move here we
could have moved to another flat no but
we did we did have to do it because
it was what was needed so we had to do
it
what I'm saying is we could have played
it we could have played it safe when
have we ever played it so
that's a good question we haven't the
whole point of trigonometry is that you
never play it safe you just don't
if we played it safe none of this would
exist that's true the podcast wouldn't
exist the show wouldn't exist
nothing that we ever did was about
playing it safe that's why I succeeded
because you don't succeed by playing it
safe yeah
it's true well I hope we carry that on
then uh because yeah we've got a lot of
work and we've got some uh already got
some brilliant guests lined up for for
next year
um we've got to finish the studio we've
got to get the Neons up there's lots of
stuff that we've yet to do we've already
recorded some great interviews in here
too we've um some brilliant interviews
yeah
so what are you looking forward to next
year I'm looking forward to I should
have mentioned my tour I love my tour I
love meeting the trigonometry fans that
was so fun I did the feedback that I got
from people the gigs that we did
and I say we did because the audience is
always 50 percent
always are and I couldn't have asked for
better audiences they were great and I'm
looking forward to doing more comedy I'm
looking forward to I'm going to be doing
more shows next year I'm going to be
doing some more of my tour I'm going to
do it in cities like Glasgow I'm going
to be going up to the north west so I'm
really looking forward to doing that I'm
really looking forward to doing more
comedy and just being and getting a
chance to be more creative that's what
I'm looking forward to really because
like you we've just been so focused on
this making this the very best it can be
so I actually just taking some more time
just to get back to being creative which
was always my first love anyway I'm
really looking forward to it yeah that's
exciting man that's really great for you
yeah I think it's really important
because Roy is a great comedic outlet
for you but you always love stand-up
yeah
there's nothing like it I disagree but
you you think that way yeah yeah so
that's what matters it's because you've
forgotten no no yeah I haven't you you
and I have done live shows we did a live
show we did two live shows in Edinburgh
yeah everybody's not stand up
I I just think we're we're very
different people psychologically yeah I
think you really crave that attention
and love from the audience and I never
really cared about the audience yeah I
didn't yeah I didn't it's like I think
it was either Bill Hicks or George
Carlin when he was getting heckled uh he
he said to the Heckler they're here for
me and I am too yeah yeah yeah like that
was always I mean maybe it's slightly
Psychopathic but I I I I always wanted
to get away from a gig the moment I was
done I never really wanted to meet
audiences with our shows I do yeah
because they're trigonometry fans but at
stand up I never really wanted to do
that I did it when I was doing my own
show a little bit and it was fun but I
never really felt
that desire but I think you really like
that yeah and it's important that's why
to use stand up for so special to me
that's why I don't do it anymore if it
was that special to me I'd find a way to
do it yeah but I don't you know I am
much more excited about my sub stack
than I am about ever doing stand up
again yeah like I am really enjoying
writing and the book showed me that
writing books is not the way to go uh
it doesn't mean I won't do another book
at some point if I feel like I really
want to get something substantive out
there but my sub stack is really
exciting to me I'm writing articles all
the time I get to express my opinion and
because you know I used to write for
various newspapers and and
um but now I can write about whatever I
want I don't have to tie it to a current
news event not everything has to be you
know look over here you know I can I can
write about something more more
significant or something that happens
three years ago that I think is relevant
to today or put things in context in a
way that you'd never get an opportunity
to and I really enjoy writing I always
have done
so I'm I'm really uh excited about that
in addition but but the thing is we've
got gigantic plans for trigonometry uh
not only the America trips but also the
guests that we're going to get here and
all sorts of other stuff that we'll
we'll be talking about next year and you
know uh one of the things we realized is
that we need to improve our social media
and Community Management game on locals
um
we're also getting to the point where
we're always getting so big that frankly
given the outrageous [ __ ] that we say on
there that we need to consider pay
Walling that or paywalling most of that
not not because we want to you know make
more money from it just because we we're
eventually going to get attacked for you
know people we don't live in a world
where people understand jokes anymore no
and the stuff that we say on there is
all done with tongue-in-cheek with humor
but all it takes is for some [ __ ] from
the guardian to clip it out of context
and suddenly we find ourselves in the
middle of having to explain why we wear
a naughty hat on and do the Nazi voice
for a joke right
um
so it may be the case that we put out
shorter clips on YouTube after the raw
is done or it goes on local whatever
we'll work it out but you know there's
going to be interesting things going on
and and changes happening which people
always love they love to change them
yeah they do especially like when we
just swap seats yeah people have a
meltdown when we change seeds so let's
see what happens when we change other
stuff around but
um you know I'm really excited for next
year
um and I also feel like we had a
Christmas party a couple of days ago and
having most and he unfortunately
couldn't get everyone here
um but most of the people I think had so
much fun and they you know our team
loves being here they love working on
the show
um and it's exciting building that with
them as well it is it is it's so
invigorating building this
it's really
seeing this come together is honestly
one of the most gratifying things that
we've done
because what we're doing is we're taking
a step into the unknown yeah and it's
scary
but
it's the only way to live
because the edge yeah of your bank
balance literally but because
if you play it safe
if you do what everybody else has done
then you're never really going to be
truly successful no and but you're also
not being true to yourself yeah I don't
think being like everyone else has ever
been what either of us has wanted no
that's why we do this yeah you know
man it's been a it's been an incredible
year and you know
that that growth that we're constantly
going through is addictive you know it
is addictive and you know what
because when I come when we came back
from America there was various personal
things it was quite a tough time it was
a tough time for me
and
the thing that I realized and look it's
a truism and everyone knows it but it
sometimes you need a good
you need to go through a tough time in
order to appreciate it you learn far
more when things aren't going well both
about other people and yourself
than you ever do when things are going
well because when things are going well
you know
you don't have to really look at
yourself
you don't really have to think to
yourself think about you know your your
actions or your behavior or your manner
of being or all of these things but when
things are going uh tough
that's the moment
and actually if you
you prepare to take on those lessons you
come out a lot stronger and a lot better
even though the process of learning
those lessons
is not pleasant
yeah and I know exactly what you're
talking about and you know you had
various personal things with family and
uh you know you and I are always trying
to work out the best way for us and
sometimes that we argue and it's
difficult and painful and whatever but
the the thing that I've really learned
this year is that
look
I I've always been a driven person and
I've always been successful in the
things that I've done
uh I'm not saying I've always been super
I haven't I haven't been super wealthy
but if I've done something I've done it
well and I've had success in it that's
all I'm saying I'm not trying to be
arrogant
um and so I think when
you know trigonometry goes well and I've
got this book and I I've got this and
I've got that and everything's going
great it's easy to think in that moment
that you know I'm this and I'm that and
I've but the truth is that
the the biggest lesson for me
out of recent years and I've done this
is if you want to do something
meaningful you can't do it by yourself
yeah you know and uh
you've really taken this you know I
remember I hope you don't mind me
telling the story but the first time
that we I said to you let's do this
podcast and you were like okay let's do
it I said okay cool I've got some
contacts uh that I'll get some people on
and then I came in and I was like okay
I've got I've got people my homegrown
who's a former presidential advisor to
two U.S presidents and you looked at me
I thought I thought your ass was going
to fall out like you were terrified yeah
right but you've stepped up so much yeah
and you've grown so much we we all have
of course but for you especially I think
coming from a pure comedy background
this was a big shift and you you know
doing the admin that comes with
trigonometry was a challenge for you and
you've really done incredibly well even
though it wasn't always easy for you you
know
um
and likewise I mean think about like
this this studio being built
Anton who's our producer he came he
joined trigonometry to edit the audio
and the video right and he basically is
just overseen construction of a tens of
thousands of pounds project
by himself
in the middle of dealing with you and I
having covid and him having he was the
ad flu and all this other [ __ ] and he's
just completed this and we've got you
know Elliot who's our intern barely gets
any money and he's created this amazing
Vlogs and he's helping Anton and Sophie
and our other video I don't know if she
wants to be named they've stepped up
their game in terms of the content that
we put out and Harman is doing a great
job and you know showing our image like
everyone is really working their asses
off to make the show what it is and
we've got other people who are going to
be hopefully joining you know helping us
improve other bids and that's that's
what I've realized for me is
I've I've always been a lone wolf in my
life but working with you and working
with our team has shown me you can be
alone wolf I'm good at what I do I I
could if I wanted to you know if we
could pack trigonometry and I could go
and write and do do whatever I'd be fine
but if you wanted to create something
actually meaningful you need to do it
with other people absolutely it's it's
the
it's the you need the band
you need the band yeah you know yeah
that's what it is and we're the band
we've got a great band here and we've
got a great band so
thank you for watching thank you for
listening thank you for taking part
thank you for sending super chats
thank you for supporting us
we couldn't have done it without you
[Music]